[Musique]
un gouvernement minoritaire novembre
une nouvelle étoile brille dans le ciel
canadien
une étoile artificielle
si le satellite de télécommunication
Annick A1 le Canada devient alors le
premier pays à posséder à satellite de
télécommunications domestiques en orbite
géostationnaire c'était il y a 50 ans
perché sur cette orbite géostationnaire
le satellite Annick A1 dans le nom
signifie petit frère en inouktitoute
semble immobile au-dessus de nos têtes à
longueur d'année en fait il suit la
vitesse de rotation de la Terre ce qui
lui permet de couvrir une région du
globe en particulier sur sa tête une
antenne est pointée vers la terre
la mission danita1 déployée sur
l'ensemble du vaste territoire canadien
des services de la radio de la
télévision et de la téléphonie le
nouveau satellite permet non seulement
aux communautés du Nord de regarder des
émissions télévisées en direct pour la
première fois mais aussi d'acheminer du
contenu culturel autochtone vers des
autres régions
[Musique]
exploitée par la compagnie canadienne
telsat et lancée depuis la Floride le
satellite Annick A1 et le premier d'une
longue série de satellites du même nom
quelques mois après ce premier lancement
deux autres satellites a seront lancés
Annick A2 et Annick A3 viendront appuyer
leur grand frère en desservant une
centaine de stations terrestres au
Canada
en tout 16 satellites de la Syrie Annick
seront lancés dans quelques-uns sont
encore au service aujourd'hui notamment
Annick G1 le dernier de la série
quant à Annick A1 dans l'espérance de
vie était à l'origine de 7 ans le plus
vieux des petits frères a tiré sa
révérence après 10 ans de loyaux
services aujourd'hui il continue à aérer
au dessus de nos têtes mais sur une
orbite dites cimetière loin de potentiel
collision sur l'autoroute des satellites
fonctionnelles
[Musique]